welcome back to PJ chain Design This is
PJ start earring is really popular and
today I would like to show you how to
make this Rose pedal start earring with
the prong setting right in the middle
are you ready let's get
[Music]
started so we are going to starting with
the stone and you can download the stone
at the link uh in the description below
just need to sign up the news later and
once you download it open it and you can
change to whatever size you want by 3D
scale with the gumball if you want it to
be exact size what you can also do is to
um using a 3D scale and make sure your
vertex is on at the bottom for the all
snap and then you can type it for
whatever size you want so that's say I
want 3.5 mm and all I need to do is move
it back to the center with the line
centers just type it zero here
okay so this will be our Stone here you
can move it to whatever uh place you
want as long as they are right in the
center the height is doesn't really
matter and I would like to start in
making the prong first so let me lock
the stone here so we won't accidentally
to change it and I would like to have uh
a straight line go like this and in my
uh course I explained a lot about the
differences between the song setting and
also um for the rendering in terms of
the way of a model and I'm am always uh
using the way for the stone setting or
for the Jeweler to set a stone on it um
it's not necessary just for the
rendering so we simply want to pip in
this guy about this size the pr size
here seems is a little bit weak for this
Stone size so and I want to increase it
if you wanted to know like what is the
proper size for the prong there's a
weight of a setting there's a minimum
but there actually no maximum it depends
on you know the look that you like so I
simply want to have a six prong so let
me just go ahead to Polar array and type
it Center is zero and I wanted to have
uh
360° for six of
them and that's what I get there we also
need a rail to holding all the prom
there so I'm going to lock the prong one
more time here and then coming into the
front view I'm going to just draw a
square or something like this I might
want it to Tilted it a little bit but we
may not need it um to tilt it uh it's
really depends on the pedal that we
create maybe we just going to trim the
bottom all together so now I'm going to
make it a little bit bigger and then
simply coming into the all four view I'm
going to use under the surface and you
have something called revolve okay and
then you want to pick up this curve and
we want the Revol AIS is starting from
the zero coming at the front view
holding the shift key and hold like this
and so this profile is going to follow
the AIS we just defined and go
360° and then so we'll get a Surface
like that now let me unlock all of them
and this is what we get there now let's
work on the pedal and I'm going to come
into other layer so I can lock the layer
so won't uh accidentally to work on
those all right so the pedal is going to
look like this they are going
[Music]
to
looking something like
this and make sure I want to go back to
the end point here and of course you if
they don't look good you can always
adjusting something like that maybe I
want to flare out a little bit so go
something like
this it can be as organic as possible so
um you can be
creative and um if you don't like it we
just change it
later and let me just move it to the
side maybe that's easier for you to see
so I simply want to snapping
into somewhere close to the
middle and draw a pedal like that but
this pedal is kind of flat and it's not
organic enough so what I like to do is
to rebuild this
one and we want to
rebuild into a degree three and we don't
need a lot of Point uh let's take a look
on the eight point it should work and
and then on the bottom one here I want
them to be more
narrow and on the top you can make them
fatter if you want to to have something
like this okay so now I have this one
here so what I wanted to do is moving
this shape and go in between here and
there so we wanted to do come to the
transform you have Orient to point so
this will be Orient from this point to
this reference point you got two
reference point and and I don't need to
copy but I do want to scale 3D so we
want a uh snapping into the quadrant to
the quadrant there so we got something
like that next what we wanted to do is
we want to split this guy by this
guy and we also want to split that guy
by this guy so you got one one two three
four four different curve here and um it
may or may not work it's always uh Worth
to try uh the command before we do any
changes so we're going to do the Loft
and going to pick up all of them and
then that's what you see there but you
see this is a opening let me turning
into the black color it's easier to see
so you do have the option there because
you got opening there you want to close
the Loft and then you click okay then
we'll get something like this and if you
don't like that you can always change
the original curve so for example this
two curves
it's going up a little bit this two
curve it's going down a little bit so
follow that kind of a similar uh
Direction and we can uh do it one more
time this time let's record a history
and we can do the Loft and just need to
pick up all of them and close the
Loft then you will have something like
that and and again if you don't like it
you can always bring up the control
point and they will keep following right
so now we have that that will be our
first padle so what we need to do is
moving in close to what we have there
let me hide this one and we can take a
look on this one okay and if you need to
be thicker or Fetter and you can kind of
edit it there it's organic shape so it
doesn't really matter you know if it is
symmetrical that's the first one and
then I would like to uh do the second
one by using the rotate and we want to
rotate it copy equal yes I do not want
it to like be a certain specific
degree but I kind of have idea for six
of them so that's one
two 3
four okay so with this Arrangement if
you because they are more like a polar
array and if you look at look at the
render view that is not as pretty right
so what I like to do is to arrange them
it's even more organic shape like and
getting bigger and bigger so this one is
a little bit bigger and of course you
can adjust the angle if that doesn't fit
for you so that one will coming out a
little bit this one will even a little
bit bigger than the second one like this
and you might want to come out a little
bit so it's kind of
a manually to working on each of the
pedal and then of course you can move
the pedal up and down and to see which
one work
well so if we take a look on the render
view one more time you will see this
might be better and also you can kind of
uh rotate it if that uh work for you
better
then we need to continue it to creating
this pedal so I'm going to using the
rotate tool one more time and
making
somewhere there in between and this one
actually I want them to go bigger you
can com in out and then can get thicker
if they want
to and once you uh done your first layer
Arrangement then you got this one by
rotate it and we just keep rotating
bunch of
them and make sure copy equal yes and
this time I want them to go all in
between the
pedal and keep rearrange until you find
the position is right for you and where
on the outside you may want them to open
it a little bit
more so it will give you more of the
layer look okay and once they are
finished this is what I did before it
will give you that layer looking thing
and just have the post in the back then
you will finish this earring I hope you
enjoy the video if you want to be a
jwelry care designer Stone setting is
the most knowledge you have to have but
don't worry I have a JY design Stone
setting mini course that is completely
free free for you that will help you to
start learning Stone setting for jury
cat we're going to talk about Stone
setting concept how to make a PR set and
show you how to custom made your own PR
set the course sign up link is in the
description below I'm sure you will
enjoy it thank you for watching and see
you next
[Music]